after watching season eight dozens of
times and slowly losing my soul to the
abyss of dog [ __ ] storytelling
i decided to take a look at season one
of game of thrones to get a sense of
when it was a great show
when you play the game of thrones you
win or you die
it has obviously taken a large downturn
after season seven and i really wanted
to understand why the earlier seasons
were so much better
most people say that it was just the
writing but i'll take a closer look than
just saying writing good and writing bad
so the question is how does season one
operate in a way that makes it one of
the best seasons of game of thrones
so i'll go over five main reasons as to
why season one is so
goddamn great there is no middle ground
so for the first point i want to talk
about the efficiency of storytelling
that season one has
not next year not tomorrow
first of all season one has a lot to do
in terms of getting everything
started it has to introduce us to the
world of game of thrones
show us the different regions cities
houses
develop over 70 characters set up the
relationships between all of them
foreshadow upcoming events in the story
and set up the driving conflict of the
show
that is a lot of content for any first
season to deal with
that and most other shows only have to
deal with a handful of characters
but somehow game of thrones can deal
with copious amounts of characters
to deal with this massive undertaking
season 1 has to be more efficient in its
execution
of setting up these different pieces of
the story
there are a lot of examples and one of
the most clever ones to me
is when ned stark is investigating the
lineage of baratheon and finds out a
revelation about joffrey
robert baratheon black affair
joffrey baratheon golden head
the reason why this is efficient
storytelling is because this scene
accomplishes two goals at the same time
on one hand netstar is propelling the
plot forward with a twist reveal that
joffrey is a lannister
and on the other hand we get exposition
on the other houses of westeros
and we learn more about the world since
ned stark has to read a book titled
the lineage in histories of the great
houses of the seven kingdoms
to move the plot forward we get free
exposition
if this was figured out in an
alternative way like say just
interrogating someone about the issue
then we don't get that clever addition
of exposition
also upon second watch through this
lends a lot of detail
for the viewer there is so much detail
packed into these shots
that you can practically just pause the
show and read it
although the handwriting is pretty
abysmal another clever example of the
efficient storytelling
is that arya's instructor cereal
pharrell is from braavos
the reason why this is efficient is
because syrio educates us
about braavos which just so happens to
be where arya goes because of the
faceless men
just like the scene with ned stark this
scene serves two purposes
we build arya's character through her
learning how to fight and
we get the added benefit of learning
more about the world through serial
pharrell
nine years serio pharrell was first
sought to the sea lord of braavos
this is not the dance of the westeros we
are learning this
is the braavos dance there is only one
god
and his name is death by combining
different requirements that the story
has to hit like world building and
character development
the audience can optimally be immersed
in the world and not feel bored
just so an even smaller example of
efficient storytelling
that is much more subtle takes place in
the very beginning of the show
since we have to establish a lot of
relationships between characters
the show has to find an optimal way to
establish those relationships quickly
this example is between jon snow and
lady catelyn
in the course of like three shots the
show establishes that catelyn chose to
stand towards
jon snow this lets the viewers know
their dynamic
early on and it shows us how bastards
are viewed which will be a recurring
conflict for jon snow in the first
season
you you're ned stark's bastard aren't
you
did i offend you sorry to put all this
together
the writers have to trust the intellect
of the audience
the story doesn't actively hold our hand
and in general it rewards people who pay
close attention
since there is so much information the
show has to set up
some of that information is in the
details thus
the intellect of the audience is
rewarded with finding out more about the
story and
world this is why season 1 of game of
thrones is so intriguing
and it also helps that the first season
plays like a mystery which requires the
protagonist to soak up a lot of
information to figure out solution
to the primary conflict your older
brother was trained to lead and you were
trained to follow
i was also trained to kill my enemies
your grace
as was i it just so happens that
everything the protagonist takes in we
also take in everything we learn about
the world doesn't become a chore
like bran learning about the different
houses with maester lewin
overall in season 1 there is practically
no filler
every scene has a purpose and because of
that the show is very engaging and you
just want to keep watching more
unlike the later seasons where there is
filler and also less
episodes so the difference in efficient
storytelling
is staggering
so this is mostly going into the second
reason as to why season 1 works so well
which is its sub-genre
season 1 feels so unique from the other
seasons of the show because its core dna
is a detective story we follow ned stark
while he tries to figure out who killed
jon aaron
and what he knew it just so happens that
this all takes place in a big fantasy
world
by using this familiar genre that people
recognize the show can increase the
retention rate of people who don't
normally watch fantasies
we have all seen murder mysteries before
but there isn't a lot of fantasy murder
mysteries
bringing in this familiarity it gets
people on board and the conflict is
recognizable
so it is therefore easier to follow and
you really need a clear conflict to
follow so that the audience can take in
the world without any sign of confusion
it is made very clear in the beginning
of the show that the main reason why ned
stark goes to king's landing is to
figure out the mystery behind john aaron
if this news is true and the lannisters
conspire against the throne
who but you can protect the king they
murdered the last hand
now you are there to take the job along
this adventure we are slowly given
exposition and none of it feels forced
in this light the subgenre fits
perfectly for its first season
another reason why i think season 1 is
so great is because of the
the first season has a much slower pace
than the rest of the show
and this comes with multiple benefits
firstly
this is an introductory season so you
need to have a slow pace to ease the
audience into the world
also with this slow pace it supplements
the subgenre of the show and allows the
mystery of jon aaron to be explored to
its full extent
you are the king's hand and the king is
a fool your friend
i know but a fool and doomed unless you
save him with the ability to slow things
down the show can also include more
detail
with more detail this makes the viewing
experience more enjoyable because you
are picking up on things that are more
subtle
and this also makes re-watching the show
much more fun
another effect from the slow piece of
the season is that the tone of the show
feels more gritty
soft fat boys like you would have lasted
a fortnight on you
and still had bones left over for soup
season one marinates moments and molds
the characters that react to those
moments
one of the best examples of this is the
very beginning where we get an extended
sequence of ned stark beheading a
deserter
this sets the tone of the season
perfectly and we get character
development for several people
we have bran as he's first witnessing
justice we have an example of ned
stark's code
of passing the sentence and swinging the
sword and we have other subtle reactions
from rob
theon and john also with this slower
pace
we tend to get more dialogue i'll go
into the dialogue more later
but dialogue scenes in the first season
are so much better than any action scene
in the later seasons
in essence the characters use words to
spar against each other
because as varus points out information
is power
and not long after that when i saw you
escorting a certain
foreign dignitary council business
of course you would have friends from
across the narrow sea
you're from there yourself after all
we're friends
aren't we lord varys i would say some of
the best fight scenes are between varys
and littlefinger
because they are literally fighting with
their wits also with these scenes we get
the added benefit of learning more about
their character
instead of a popcorn action scene where
we don't get a lot of information about
someone
two people whacking their swords at each
other is entertaining for a time
but a fierce battle of dialogue offers
more in value for the overall story
the problem with the later seasons is
that it loses the balance of action and
dialogue that the first few seasons have
sure you can have extended action
sequences but it quickly becomes dull
when your characters drown out from an
over reliance on action this isn't an
issue with season one
season one uses its action very
meticulously
and even when there is an action scene
it isn't long and drawn out for visual
spectacle
but it is more like a samurai doll to
determine a character's value
like the fight between jaime and ned
cements this fact they are basically
having a battle for their reputation
and the fight has more to offer than
just action
also with the change of pace in the
daenerys plotline we get some more fight
scenes with the dothraki because it's
within their nature
that want for action that audience
exhibits is mostly quenched because the
dothraki culture is more violent
also with jon snow he is training to be
in the night's watch so that also offers
more action
along with cyril pharrell teaching arya
how to fight
dead so the pace in general isn't a
complete slog and there's a lot of
variety
season one finds that sweet spot of
balancing slow burn mystery and the
addition of action through separate plot
lines
lord snow here grew up in a castle
spitting down on the likes of you
another point that i have to mention
while on the subject of pace is how long
it takes people to travel around
westeros
obviously in the later seasons they
practically feel like they are
teleporting
and that also accounts for the breakneck
pace of the later seasons
but with season 1 it actually takes like
a month to travel from king's landing to
winterfell
take me to your crypt i want to pay my
respects we've been riding for a month
my love
surely the dead can wait ned it makes
the show feel more grounded and
realistic
it's like oh it actually took you that
long to get from point a to point b
and it gives you a sense of what the
scale of the world is like
when daenerys is zipping from
dragonstone to highgarden we lose that
sense of scale that they are on an
entire continent
but in season 1 when the characters are
going on long journeys
they give them moments to develop their
character with more dialogue
scenes like ned stark and robert
baratheon discussing their time together
we never had the chance to be young what
they call a few chances
jon snow and tyrion talking to each
other at the campfire
tearing and brawn bickering at each
other while walking through the country
season one is able to retain that scale
of the world while simultaneously giving
us character building dialogue
all of the traveling scenes aren't
boring because we actively get dialogue
that's intriguing
remember this whatever that price
i'll beat it i like living
it does more to have these dialogue
scenes while on the road because we
actualize the world that they live in
the pacing in general because of all
this just feels much more natural
another aspect about season 1 that helps
a slower pace
is the use of cliffhangers having those
sharp twists in the narrative keeps
things interesting and unpredictable
also by having them at the end of your
episodes it instills a need to watch the
next part of the story
it also creates tension within your
story that something bad could happen at
any time
that's why there is an aura of suspense
within season 1 which helps its subgenre
being a mystery slash detective story
since there isn't a lot of action the
filmmakers tend to make up for that
in deceit and betrayal as a product from
the build-up of the show's slow pace
i did warn you not to trust me
when ned stark gets betrayed in season 1
it feels much better than any foreign
portrayal in season 7 or 8 because of
its build
up a mirror of ned stark's betrayal is
in season 7 where sansa kills
littlefinger
the difference with season 7 is that
there is no build up to allude to the
outcome of littlefinger's death
a scene happens off screen where bran
informs arya and sansa about all the
wrongdoings littlefinger has done
by not showing the audience's
information you are creating a twist for
the sake of shock value
for season 1 however they literally
build up the betrayal of ned stark and
even tease at it when littlefinger warns
that stark not to trust him
but baelish perhaps i was wrong to
distrust you
distrusting me was the wisest thing
you've done since you climbed off your
horse
since season one inherently has that
slower pace for the story to build up
his drama effectively
it will always have a better payoff
because of that
so the next reason why season 1 is so
great is because of the dialogue
but what makes good dialogue good
dialogue isn't just witty lines
it's dialogue that perfectly reflects
the character within a world
the future of our family will be
determined in these next few months
we could establish a dynasty that will
last a thousand years
or we could collapse into nothing as the
targaryens
with dialogue that reflects character in
a good way we can learn more about them
and become invested whether or not they
are protagonists or the antagonist
so in season one game of thrones has its
biggest challenge
because it has to set up the majority of
the characters in the show and make them
all feel compelling and interesting
that sounds like a massive challenge but
season 1 efficiently shows us enough
from each character to give us a good
idea as to who they are
you'll be a soldier
and on top of that they heavily allude
to future plot lines in their earlier
dialogue which further increases
re-watchability because stuff like that
could have gone over your head
the next time we see each other
we'll talk about your mother
so the dialogue in essence serves three
purposes
it builds character it moves the plot
forward
and it builds the world around them so
naturally because the dialogue hits
those three points it will always feel
engaging
the reason why the later seasons have a
massive decline in quality of dialogue
is because most of it only serves one of
those points
that point being that most of the
dialogue is only there to move the plot
forward
this is one of the reasons why jon snow
felt so hollow in season 8.
since most of his dialogue became very
repetitive that mostly revolved around
him complaining about not wanting to be
king
his character became very uninteresting
i never wanted a crown
i told you i don't want it it doesn't
matter what you want
i don't want it i never wanted it i
never asked for it
i don't want them to kneel for me
however in season one he comes off as a
normal fleshed out character
who has dialogue with more variety also
the quality of the lines in the script
were much more brilliant
for example there are a lot more uses of
literary devices like similes
metaphors and hyperboles that make the
dialogue sound much more intellectual
and make it feel of higher quality the
person that delivers most of those
literary devices
is tyrion and in episode one alone he
has like four memorable lines
never forget what you are the rest of
the world will not
wear it like armor all dwarves are
bastards in their father's eyes
i'm sorry i've begun the feast a bit
early and this
is the first of many courses while in
season eight all i can remember is an
overabundance of [ __ ] jokes
also speaking of the use of humor the
humor is never in the forefront of any
of the scenes which is a great thing
there is humor in season 1 but it's
generally used more sparsely and
naturally
instead of the characters going out of
their way to make jokes you heard the
hand the king's too fat for his armor
go find the breastplate stretcher now
also it tends to stick with the more
lighthearted and humorous characters
like robert baratheon
tyrion and braun the humor never breaks
character
unlike season 8 where even cersei seems
to be making jokes
i wanted those elephants in season 8
braun basically loses any semblance of
intellect and just becomes a quip
machine to make the audience
laugh and that title's worth as much as
a blonde air from your brother's bulls
how are his eyes where men believe shut
your mouth
his jokes in season 1 are actually
natural and generally come in response
as to what other characters say give me
ten good men and some climbing spikes
i'll impregnate the [ __ ] since season
one of game of thrones doesn't overly
rely on comedy as a crutch
the quality in general is much better
than the later seasons
because of that the show can actually
take itself seriously and effectively
build the drama for the last quick point
i want to talk about the uniqueness of
season 1.
a part of the reason why season 1 is so
memorable is because it has a different
format from the rest of the seasons the
format of season 1 is much different
because it is portrayed to follow the
point of view of one primary protagonist
we do have different subplots but most
of the conflict derives from ned stark's
story
for the other seasons we follow multiple
different subplots that eventually enter
weave
but for season 1 we had one primary
driving plot that everyone was attached
to
by breaking this familiar format of
killing your main protagonist the
audience is then floored and left in awe
to see where the show will go
it will always come as a shock before i
started the show his death was spoiled
for me
but it was still surprising because of
how unconventional that turn was
season 1 breaks the rules of
storytelling by killing that primary
protagonist and will always be special
to watch even for the fifth time
i will always think that people will
look fondly in season one of game of
thrones because the later seasons just
became blockbustery
with a sole reliance on spectacle
i also think that most of the stories
like tyrion's adventure
ned stark solving a murder mystery
daenerys finding out who she is
and becoming a badass jon snow becoming
a member of the night's watch
are all just fun and interesting the
whole season doesn't have any dull plot
plotlines and from the 5 reasons i
talked about i think season 1
is one of the best seasons of the show
[Music]
you